ceci est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
donc
[Applaudissements]
ceci
euh
[Applaudissements]
est
étranger
[Applaudissements]
moi d'accord
puis-je vous donner une page les gars
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
que
nous avons perdu un an depuis le 4 janvier à
parler de savoir s'il est suicidaire ou non,
c'était le piège réprimandant les décisions
salut les gars
mon
[Applaudissements]
euh
étranger
[Applaudissements]
oh
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super
oh
[Musique]
[Musique] d'
accord
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que
je me sens comme
[Applaudissements]
désolé
je veux dire
[Applaudissements]
i
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toutouais
[Applaudissements]
regardez
euh
[Applaudissements]
dites au monde
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est
oh d'
accord
il a dit um
loin  plus sincèrement
[Applaudissements]
merci
tu étais avant ça oh c'était lui
tu es là depuis cinq heures ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Appl  ause]
euh
[Applaudissements]
oh ouais
merci
[Applaudissements]
euh
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tout ce que vous voulez
merci merci
dites juste au monde que je pense que je vis
vraiment simple
pas un bon
pack d'essai là-bas  suggère
qu'il va en fait être
comme
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements
] c'est un tournant pour le monde
même si vraiment
860 ans d'histoire ont été actuellement
totalement
inconfortables c'est de loin probable
bien que
ce ne soit pas un problème
[Applaudissements]
euh et puis environ cinq  quelques minutes plus tard, l'
un d'eux passe avec comme ces
deux cuivres
[Applaudissements]
juste couvert de clara, puis son compagnon
qui s'est précédemment échappé arrive et
commence à lui donner une vue bientôt
aussi
[Applaudissements]
non non d'
accord ce que vous voulez
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excellent
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'importe quelle décision
euh je pense que ce sera une attaque de pointe
c'est  aussi simple que cela
ici je vais y aller
[Applaudissements]
absolument
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
oh
euh
[Applaudissements]
ok ça
va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hé
[Applaudissements]
ok
c'est
oh
je pensais
[Musique]
bonjour d'
accord
c'est
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
oh
prêt
[Applaudissements
] c'est
[Applaudissements]
merci
[  Musique]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
[Applaudissements]
gratuit gratuit
trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super
[Applaudissements
] ne décident pas par eux-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
des nations unies
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Applaudissements]
la cia prévoyait d'assassiner
[Applaudissements]
travailler pour les États-Unis d'Amérique
fcia ils ont un discours direct en direct de l'
intérieur de l'ambassade
de l'équateur
un pays souverain
directement aux États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
nous servir avec préparation et
des informations
pour ouvrir l'esprit et conspirer contre
la mèche  ed aventurier
mais avec tellement
[Applaudissements]
est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
dans les rues de Londres
je me bats pour une prédication de louange gratuite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
tout le monde doit prendre position
il ne faut pas se cacher oui il n'y a pas de
définition de la responsabilité le résultat
de cette décision aujourd'hui est la
responsabilité de toute notre société oui
nous ne voulons pas d'un tel sang
dans ce pays
maintenant
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
pour des millions de  les gens du
monde entier
[Applaudissements]
hé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas d'explication
merci
[Applaudissements]
assez court
[Musique]
nous sommes des gens nous représentons
le peuple  autour du monde qui ne sont pas
ici
et là
pour des moments joyeux
n'est pas un crime
vous n'êtes pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chrétien
malgré
et luttant toujours
pour protéger nos vies
la liberté de dépression
notre droit de connaître
la vérité
pour protéger les droits de  journalistes
des éditeurs
avec des lois
partout,
ce sera beaucoup, je serai notre
motivation
pour voir Juliana
[Applaudissements]
afin que Julian Assange
puisse voir la lumière
du soleil pour la première fois
et être avec les amis de sa famille
et nous aider à nous remettre
de la dure cruauté à
laquelle il a survécu
et  commencer le prochain chapitre de sa vie
et continuer son travail
comme le brillant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doit être libre
durian assange viens avec moi
et nous devons nous battre
dans cette bataille historique
pour gagner
pour nos enfants sera le prochain
préjugé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
s'il vous plaît
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
une décision
pas d'extradition
c'est une seule décision
pas de problèmes supplémentaires
nous
ne pouvons pas les
garçons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais bien sûr ils mettront probablement ça
dans ces magasins
c'est vraiment simple
[Musique]
j'adore ça
allez
[Musique]
ça fait
plaisir de voir
[Applaudissements]
euh
service alors dirigé par pierre été qui
maintenant en tant que chef du parti travailliste a
contribué à créer la présidence judiciaire et
diplomatique
b  y faire avancer le
système judiciaire britannique
et enfreindre la loi
qui maintient les états-unis
arbitrairement détenus
depuis 2010
la pression de belmar
pendant deux ans et demi
sa santé en général et sa
santé mentale c'est la victoire se sont détériorés d'un
coup
car la torture psychologique et les
enveloppes amusantes des traditions
nous furtifs  les responsables
qui ont travaillé avec donald trump
du cnn
cette année nous prévoyons de kidnapper
julian assange
cette année nous prévoyons de
faire fortune julian assange quand il était
à l'ambassade de l'équateur
ici
nous avons affaire à des
criminels la cia
le fbi
ils sont prêts  tuer un
journaliste innocent pour avoir dit la vérité
système judiciaire britannique hé
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'un seul
il y a une décision une décision
[Applaudissements]
trois trois
deux trois
[Applaudissements]
maintenant combien d'années cet homme va-t-il
souffrir
combien d'années
[Applaudissements]
pour avoir publié des informations véridiques
dans le bien public
tous ces adorables journalistes et p  hoto
journalistes qui sont ici aujourd'hui
quel est le message qu'ils reçoivent
sur
la valeur de la liberté de la presse dans ce
pays
partout dans le monde
il y a des violations des droits de l'homme
dans des régimes despotiques
la première chose qu'ils font est de jeter leurs
journalistes en prison c'est la première
chose qu'ils font
fermer des journaux la
première chose qu'ils font
ils nomment leurs propres
gens à la tête des
organes de presse comme nous avons vu erdogan le faire
en turquie
ils jettent les journalistes en prison est
le premier signe d'un régime despotique
que fait ce gouvernement en donnant à
julian assange un  nation les gens marchent
prison de haute sécurité un éditeur un
journaliste
honte à eux honte tout
cela ne nous amuse pas
pourquoi julian assange est à la prison de belmont le
journalisme n'est pas un crime
nous voulons vivre dans une société libre qui
valorise la liberté des valeurs de la presse
journalistes ayant le droit
et la liberté de publier la vérité pour
information
[Applaudissements]
hein
gratuit gratuit julian assange
[Musique]
[App  applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une décision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une décision
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
hé
distribuez des tracts dans la circulation qui passe
la solidarité avec le local  les gens sont
immenses
et puis nous nous promenons jusqu'aux portes
et nous chantons comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui
pour sa liberté en espérant que nos
voix atteindront ses oreilles
nos voix informeront
les personnes emprisonnées à belmar
et soutiendront cet homme
un être humain comme vous  et moi qu'est-ce qu'il
fait en prison qu'est-ce qu'il fait en
prison julian assange
qu'est-
ce que c'est
assez prison à sécurité maximale
gratuit gratuit julian assad
dans le monde entier ont été publiés et sont
toujours publiés sur les révélations
de wikileaks l'
information veut être libre veut être
partagée
les organisations publiques agissant en notre
nom
nous devons les tenir responsables
il n'y a aucune menace dans les faiblesses les
informations
produites
[Applaudissements]
par l'argent de nos impôts doivent être partagées par
les contribuables et comprises
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que la démocratie est censée être
nous donnons notre argent au gouvernement
nous donnons avec notre vote
leur
pouvoir
de gouverner  et décider,
mais leur part du marché
est d'agir en notre nom
et de soumettre leurs actions à l'
examen du peuple
c'est ce qu'est la démocratie à propos
des réunions libres de Julian Assange
[Applaudissements]
il n'y en a qu'un seul a
écrit une lettre de décision aux juges
faisant appel  à eux de les assiéger
[Applaudissements]
de faire le bon choix de faire un
choix qui nous rendra fiers
collectivement
un jury n'enverrait jamais
Julian Assange en Amérique
mais
ce
qu'il a dit dans la
lettre,
c'est
quand il les a saisis que
nous avons lu dans les journaux pour le chef
le juge d'angleterre est le meilleur ami d'
alan duncan, le personnel étranger
chargé
d'orchestrer l'expulsion de
julian
de l'ambassade équatorienne
et la résiliation de son polit  ical
asiles a
même nommé
le juge en chef brunei
et son français de 40 ans
alan duncan n'ont pas parlé et
discuté de cette affaire entre eux
ce sont des gens qui partagent les mêmes
valeurs nous sommes très inquiets
très préoccupés par l'issue de ce
tribunal
nous sommes très reconnaissants
à des organisations journalistiques comme le
royaume-uni classifié faisant des recherches très très minutieuses et détaillées sur ces questions, ils ont révélé que le symbolisme du gouvernement britannique a conspiré pour transformer l'asile politique de ce julian assange à l'intérieur de
l'ambassade équatorienne
[Applaudissements]
ils ont détaillé en détail le
conflit de  intérêt
de la
magistrate en chef emma albus not
qui présidait la procédure au
tribunal de première instance de westminster
et a récemment été élevée il y a environ un an
à la haute cour du juge
de la famille
[Applaudissements]
intérêt financier avec le secteur
l'intérêt financier de son fils est dans
le  centrer
son propre
don d'auto-réception
[Applaudissements]
des gens
[A  applaudissements]
donc nous
demandons à juste titre
[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passe derrière ces murs
quelles sont les discussions qui ont eu
lieu avec les représentants du gouvernement
sur ce lieu hautement politique
de mon point de vue notre message est
[Applaudissements]
junior
bonjour tout le monde euh je  Je vais
d'abord dire quelque chose à propos de la
sécurité pour nous tous
je vais d'abord dire quelque chose à propos de
la sécurité de tous les journalistes qui
sont ici et
qui nous font face
votre sécurité
est en jeu
en ce qui concerne ce qui se passe dans ce
euh  chanson de la cour royale
justice
pourrons-nous utiliser ce terme
après avoir entendu le verdict d'
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est en jeu
notre sécurité une société juste institue juste des
institutions qui coopèrent justement
pour défendre nos libertés pour défendre un
journaliste qui nous a dit quoi  se
passe
dans la corruption de notre gouvernement des
actes répréhensibles d'une nature énorme
lorsque nous parlons de crimes de guerre qui ont été
révélés par wikileaks,
nous parlons du meurtre d'
enfants
nous parlons de la torture
d'enfants
commise par l'armée américaine et aussi l'armée britannique,
c'est quelque chose
de bien contre lequel toutes les personnes de bonne conscience devraient se
battre et devraient vouloir savoir,
surtout si nous payons pour cela et
surtout si le  les gens qui l'
organisent nous privent de nos libertés
nous payons pour la poursuite de
cet homme les
contribuables britanniques paient pour la
poursuite de cet homme des millions de
livres à la demande du gouvernement américain
donc ce n'est pas seulement c'est un homme et c'est
nos libertés, c'est aussi la souveraineté britannique
qui est en jeu ici,
donc
quiconque regarde cette émission que
vous êtes tous, j'espère, va
envoyer dans le monde
probablement pas ici
parce que bien sûr, où il devrait
être vu
n'est pas correctement diffusé  par la
presse grand public ici
et cela aussi
soulève une énorme question ou devrait soulever une
énorme question pour
quiconque est un citoyen britannique qui vit dans
ce
silence de pays  omission
mensonges
complicité
ce n'est pas
nous devons nous battre contre cela
et c'est ce que nous faisons ici nous
élevons une voix pour notre sécurité pour votre
sécurité pour la sécurité de notre société pour
la liberté de l'homme à l'intérieur ou de l'homme
il n'est pas là  en fait aujourd'hui, il sera,
je ne sais pas comment il sera
, il est euh
lié par vidéo par lien vidéo
de belmarsh
euh
donc
nous avons tous un intérêt dans cette
situation c'est vraiment pour ça
que je suis là
ces raisons en fait je suis ici pour
défendre
une personne que je pense être
persécutée je suis ici pour défendre
euh la liberté de la presse que j'apprécie beaucoup
et je suis aussi ici pour moi
parce que je veux vivre dans une société
où la vérité n'est pas  un crime et où les
diseurs de vérité ne sont pas emprisonnés
alors
libérez julian assange
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
nous uk
[Applaudissements]
nous devons être en sécurité dans notre propre société
nous devons être en sécurité
[Rires]
allez
[Applaudissements]
d'une manière très évidente
mais le message que nous portons est positif
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui
pour annoncer officiellement la
justice à la grande faucheuse que la
justice britannique est morte la
justice britannique est morte
cette affaire n'est pas compliquée
c'est vraiment très simple
julian assange est  un journaliste qui a
créé wikileaks pour exposer les mauvaises
choses faites par de mauvaises personnes
dans le monde,
c'est bien que ces mauvaises choses soient
exposées car cela signifie que de bonnes personnes
comme nous ont
une chance d'arrêter ces mauvaises
personnes
rapidement
et tout ce que Julian a fait
est  tout
parfaitement légal
mais cela a fait de lui des ennemis très puissants,
en particulier le gouvernement des états-unis,
alors ils ont soudoyé
oui le gouvernement des états-unis a
soudoyé
une personne appelée forderson
rappelez-vous ce nom thinkerson
le gouvernement des états-unis a soudoyé
thinkerson pour qu'il mente
en disant que julian l'a fait pirater
et le piratage est illégal
mais thordeson a maintenant admis qu'il
a menti
et julian n'a absolument rien fait d'
illégal ou  faux en
outre,
dawdison est le témoin le moins fiable que
vous puissiez imaginer,
car il a des condamnations sexuelles avec neuf
garçons mineurs ainsi que de multiples
condamnations pour fraude financière à grande échelle
et pense que
julian a menti pour qu'il puisse obtenir l'
immunité contre les poursuites
en résumé,
cette affaire n'est pas  un
penseur compliqué est le seul témoin contre
julian
et maintenant il a admis qu'il a été soudoyé
par le gouvernement des états-unis pour mentir
contre julian
c'est aussi simple que ça
donc c'est une imposture de justice absolument dégoûtante qui se
passe dans ce
petit tribunal de kangourou commencé derrière moi la
justice britannique  ne défendra
absolument rien dans le monde
si ce tribunal ne libère pas immédiatement
julian ou stone
free junior
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
témoin de l'accusation américaine
quelle blague
trois julian assange
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
l'éditeur de wikileaks
[Applaudissements]
un journaliste et un éditeur l'ont
emprisonné
à  sécurité maximale hmp belmont un
endroit des plus sinistres
22 23 heures sur 23 dans une cellule 3x2
un intellectuel
un homme pacifique
un héros pour des millions
trois sons juniors
]
[Applaudissements]
absolument
et
avec un énorme
choc et horreur,
nous avons vu que les
reportages de la BBC sont épouvantables.
manafort a rendu visite à julian et s'est
tenu à l'intérieur de l'ambassade équatoriale
trois fois,
cela
ne s'est jamais produit,
nous sommes allés trois fois devant le
gardien pour protester, enlevez l'article mensonger
non seulement cela,
mais il y a seulement quelques semaines, il a été révélé
que des journalistes travaillant pour le
gardien
recherchaient  cette histoire
savait très bien des
mois et des années avant que quelqu'un d'
autre ne sache
que julian assange a été espionné
par uc global la sécurité  entreprise
employée par le gouvernement équatorial
ils savaient que
ces journalistes savaient
que music global transcrivait
les conversations de julian assange avec ses
avocats
avec son peuple
ils leur ont donné accès
à des images de vidéosurveillance
ces journalistes n'ont jamais révélé la
vérité choquante
de ce que vous voyez global faisait ce
qui était illégal
ils  ne l'ont pas révélé, ils l'ont gardé
sous le tapis à la
place, ils ont publié un mensonge
un mensonge qui, même à ce jour, est sur le
site Web,
c'est une
honte  j'ai lu que cela
a été
autorisé c'est à quel point ils apprécient la presse gratuite
c'est à
quel point ce pays apprécie
notre force est dans notre unité nous continuons
le combat pour libérer Julian Assange nous savions
depuis le début que nous allions tout
le temps  chemin vers la cour suprême oui et la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
e
[Applaudissements]
ces imprimés des
articles et des journaux si dangereux
qu'ils doivent être tués
par Julian Assange
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
ne va pas à l'encontre de notre détermination
à continuer suffisamment de problèmes
pour un prêtre libre et un assad junior libre
[Applaudissements
] c'est une décision honteuse absolument honteuse
d'
accorder l'appel américain
pour extrader Julian Assange puis d'être
inculpé puis d'être jugé puis d'être
reconnu coupable puis d'être incarcéré pendant
175 ans
dans un établissement supermax
quelque part dans le Colorado
dégoûtant honteux
honteux maintenant  je veux dire quelque chose à
propos de ce que je comprends,
le 11 décembre,
c'est quand les juges partent en vacances
[Applaudissements]
le 11 décembre, c'est quand les juges
partent en vacances
, j'espère personnellement que les deux juges qui
ont rendu cette décision
s'étoufferont  ailes
alors qu'ils sont assis sur une plage à la Barbade
lâche lâche
maintenant
nous allons continuer cependant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[App  lause]
puis-je juste dire et rappeler à tout le monde et
je vous parle
parce que je pense que vous devriez l'être parce que je
veux que les gens sachent ce
qui est très important
ce qui est très important est que julian
sera probablement encore condamné à rester
à belmarsh le  romance un homme innocent qui
n'est pas accusé de quoi que ce soit
qui est également mal et nous continuerons
à nous battre pour qu'il soit libéré de
belle marsh pendant que ces
procédures judiciaires tournent encore et encore il
est à belmar maintenant depuis deux ans et
demi
sans inculpation  pendant la majeure partie de ce temps,
c'est une honte, cela signifie que le processus
devient une punition qui est illégale
qui est contre la loi
de ce pays et c'est aussi contre
le droit international
ces juges sont des criminels ils
enfreignent leurs propres
lois
[Applaudissements]
hé
c'est
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
suite à la célébration de la démocratie
quelle ferme
quel début sur les droits de l'homme aujourd'hui
pour
avoir cette horrible décision
fait par des enfants britanniques honteux
fidèles
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hé écoutez tout le monde
c'est vraiment simple ce n'est pas un vrai
enfant
c'est vraiment simple
le principal témoin contre julian est la
pensée
qu'il a menti goderson a dit  julian lui a demandé
de pirater si ce n'est pas vrai borderon
n'a pas admis qu'il a menti l'affaire s'est
effondrée
tout ce qui se passe jusqu'à présent ce n'est tout simplement
pas une perte de temps pour s'éloigner
des vrais problèmes
il devrait être un homme libre alors nous
aura une presse libre et ensuite nous
apprendrons les mauvaises choses qui se passent dans le monde
afin que nous puissions les empêcher de se
produire merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lord juge en chef
quelle blague
oui le brûleur scandaleux est un ami d'
aaron duncan
qui a
orchestré l'enlèvement de julian à l'
ambassade il y a deux ans et demi burnett
a 40 ans
depuis 40 ans il est un ami d'alan
duncan je  c'est vraiment scandaleux ce qui se
passe derrière nous dans cette voiture c'est
juste une imposture absolue ce n'est pas un
vrai procès nous pensions dans la vie l'affaire
contre julian s'est effondrée c'est
vraiment aussi simple que ça c'est corrompu
absolument corrompu pourri de bout en bout
ouais
allez chercher le gros obtenez le gros
venez sur les
assurances diplomatiques américaines
mon ridicule est qu'ils ont accepté
les assurances diplomatiques américaines en disant qu'elles
étaient des assurances solennelles
comment n'importe qui croirait quoi que ce soit de
la bouche diplomatique des États-Unis
après avoir tiré et envahi le  la vie privée
et a volé la propriété de julian assange est incroyable
, l'affaire est renvoyée devant
le tribunal de première instance de l'ouest
pour qu'ils reconsidèrent depuis le
portefeuille américain qu'ils ont décidé à nouveau
, puis à penny patel,
alors continuez à vous battre, tout le monde continue à se battre
parce que la justice n'a pas été  servi cette
fois et nous resterons avec elle
julian a dit
qu'il y a de la solidarité dans l'oppression
et nous devons être unis
dans la resp  onse nous devons être unis dans la
réponse tout le monde continue à lutter contre
cette injustice
nous devions arrêter le lent meurtre de notre
ami et héros julian assange parce
que c'est ce qu'ils essaient de faire
et nous savons que la cia espionnait et nous
savons qu'ils voulaient  tuez-le,
nous devons l'abattre
je ne suis pas sûr que mon peuple soit sorti maintenant
c'est absolument scandaleux ce que nous
réprimons la presse libre la presse libre
est la base de la démocratie c'est
absolument
[Musique]
nous voulons un vrai procès inéquitable où la
vérité  sort quand julian assange se
libère
gratuitement julian
[applaudissements]
hassan assange
j'ai tellement honte d'être britannique
[applaudissements]
[musique]
de toute cette
lutte concernant l'attaque contre julian
assange est la manière dont  le
gouvernement de l'uf l'état américain
qu'il soit de gauche ou de droite qu'il s'agisse de
lois républicaines ou démocratiques pour prendre le
contrôle
de toutes les démocraties libérales occidentales voici de
quoi il s'agit d'
un système
judiciaire américain judiciaire américain de  des policiers venant dans
un autre pays souverain dans ce cas,
le royaume-
uni prend en charge son système judiciaire
pour contrôler ce qui se passe dans ces tribunaux
parce qu'ils
doivent extrader
un citoyen australien
pour qu'il soit inculpé devant un tribunal
américain en vertu des lois américaines
pour avoir révélé des informations par lesquelles
ces informations ont été révélées
wikileaks en europe
en europe
où cet éditeur
journaliste australien vivait
pourquoi pas un procès devant jury
pourquoi le public n'est-il pas là
pourquoi le public a-t-il été refusé
pour les 27e et 28e audiences
il y avait six places
autorisées dans la galerie publique pour que le
public puisse voir
justice qui est une pierre angulaire de
la pratique juridique britannique
[Musique]
éthiquement moralement
légalement
mauvais,
nous devons résister et quand je dis nous,
je veux dire
vous tous
ainsi que nous parce que
quand
si nous ne résistons pas
quand la porte vient quand la main
frappe  votre épaule, il n'y aura
personne pour vous défendre à moins que nous ne combattions maintenant
et que nous ne combattions pour cet homme et que nous ne combattions
pour la démocratie et la liberté
[  Musique]
lire entre les lignes
une raison du retard de la
sortie de stella est parce qu'elle pleure de tout son
cœur,
nous devons nous unir et dire au
monde que ce n'est pas une bonne justice, c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
oh merci
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez pu comprendre que
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les journalistes des différentes
sources que vous prenez
extrêmement sérieux
comme vous le devriez et comme je suis content de vous voir
je veux dire que ce gars
nous continuerons à élever la voix
pour julian assange
pour la liberté de la presse pour la justice dans
ce pays et même pour la justice dans
le monde
nous  avoir une veillée
tous les mercredis à piccadilly circus
je suis désolé australia house australia
house
[Applaudissements]
est
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très très rapidement puis avant parce
qu'il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui veut euh
vous parler comme  bien
nous nous rencontrons
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que
nous nous rencontrons régulièrement à l'australia house
qui est à seulement 300 mètres de cette façon
tous les mercredis de
15h à 17h.
s'il vous plaît
tous les journalistes dépensez-le envoyez ceci
et et la prison de belmarsh tous les samedis
le 18 décembre il
y aura une veillée à la prison de belmosh de 14h à 18h
pour être là soyez là montrez votre soutien
[Musique]
montrez au monde qu'il y a du soutien  et je
voudrais également souligner un autre
point: dans les médias grand public,
très peu de couverture est jamais accordée
aux
partisans dans les rues
soutenant ce problème particulier ou tout autre
problème
silence les gens ne s'opposent à
rien de tout cela nous
parlons nous le diffusons
nous sommes les partisans
maintenant je travaillais au ministère britannique
des affaires étrangères
je soutiens julian assange parce que quand je
travaille maintenant je travaillais pour un ministre qui était
en charge de la consommation
il avait un c particulier  comme en thaïlande
où nous avions un trafiquant de drogue qui
allait être exécuté
ce ministre avait
eu un
[Applaudissements]
donc je travaillais au ministère des affaires
étrangères avec un ministre des affaires étrangères qui était en
charge des affaires consulaires il avait un
cas particulier en thaïlande  où un trafiquant de
drogue devait être exécuté par la
police
et il a dit que même s'il avait un fils qui
était mort d'une overdose d'héroïne et qu'il
détestait cet homme pour être un trafiquant de drogue,
il devait dire non tu ne peux pas tuer cet
homme c'est  contre les droits de l'homme et c'est
contre tout ce que nous défendons pour que le trafiquant de
drogue obtienne ses
soins conscients de nos ministres, mais pourtant
Julian Assange n'a rien fait de
mal sauf dire la vérité sur les
abus américains à l'étranger,
il est incarcéré et il ne peut pas voir ses
enfants à Noël alors  boris johnson
tu vois tes deux nouveaux enfants à noël
honte absolue sur toi tu es dégoûtant
tu es tout mauvais et dominic rob qui
était un si gentil jeune homme avant
d'entrer en politique honte sur toi
toi  sont une honte absolue pour notre
pays
et j'ai honte d'être britannique
appelant un prisonnier politique notre
prisonnier politique
il ne convient pas au
récit de l'establishment occidental selon lequel oui l'
ouest a des prisonniers politiques
c'est une réalité ce n'est pas seulement moi il y a
un tas d'autres  les gens aussi
aucun état n'accepte les gens d'or qu'il
emprisonne ou détient pour des
raisons politiques prisonniers politiques
ils ne les appellent pas des prisonniers politiques
en chine
ils ne les appellent pas des prisonniers politiques c'est l'
azerbaïdjan
et ils ne les appellent pas des
prisonniers politiques aux états-unis
Royaume-Uni ou Suède,
il est absolument terrible d'avoir ce
genre d'auto-tromperie.
Ce sont les mots de Julian Assange
dans ses propres mots.
C'est tout ce que nous avons de ses mots pour le
moment
.  com
julian assange dans ses propres mots
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
il y a des gens dans des situations bien
pires que moi
il y a aussi des gens dans de meilleures
situations  ns que vous devez être très
diligent pour y faire face en
essayant de faire de l'exercice
avec les lumières parce qu'il n'y a
pas de soleil, alors vous essayez d'avoir des lumières
allumées au bon moment de la journée et éteintes
à d'autres moments, c'est comme si les gens travaillaient
au nord  pôle ou dans la
station spatiale vous devez faire face à l'
absence de lumière
mais la lumière est le tueur
qui règle votre horloge ce sont les mots
de julian assange six ans et demi à l'
intérieur de cette
ambassade sans nuit nuit très triste
et il est le gars  qui nous a
tant éclairés
grâce à son travail avec wikileaks
publication de la publication
sur la façon dont le cru est conduit
au nom du public mais sans
notre consentement alors
que nous attendons d'écouter les paroles de
stella
morris nous la soutenons elle et sa famille
ils font partie de notre société
ils sont une famille qui souffre nous soutenons
stella morris et sa famille par
solidarité
il pourrait être l'un des nôtres
Chaque fois
qu'il a révélé des secrets gouvernementaux, il a révélé
des crimes d'entreprise,
il y a une différence,
un crime est un crime
simplement parce que vous êtes le gouvernement de
votre entreprise si vous décidez de coller
des déchets toxiques au large des côtes africaines,
c'est un crime.
l'avenir de nos
enfants et nous ne vous laisserons pas le
prendre vous devez vous battre sur vos mains
un combat sérieux nous mourrons pour julian
assange
nous sommes
tous les mercredis nous sommes à l'
ambassade d'australie
de trois à cinq tous les samedis nous sommes
à  la prison de belmont arrive aussi avec l'
académie ouais les deux endroits dont
nous avons besoin jillian ce sont du soutien
il y a des années c'était un journaliste appelé
gary wood il a fait exactement la même chose qu'il a
révélé au
congrès cia crimes il n'a jamais obtenu le
soutien de la communauté julian a besoin de la
nasa et moi '  je suis inquiet des journalistes non corporatifs
je comprends que vous devez
acheter une autre piscine j'appelle
tous les journalistes indépendants et je
remercie mieux match pour bloomingford the
gre  y zone
jimmy gaul gardien démon
sarcasme tous les gens tous les
journalistes indépendants ont fait le travail que vous
refusez de faire le
matérialisme parce que c'est tout vous avez
pitié de vos fils juniors
mesdames et messieurs je veux vous associer une
question à vous tous maintenant
julian assange est à l'intérieur  une
prison depuis 10 ans à l'intérieur des balises et
à l'intérieur de l'ambassade équatorienne
il se battait pour notre liberté d'
expression la capacité de sortir et de parler
alors en ce moment nos voyages nos mots et
nos pensées sont restreints
censurés et supprimés
afin que julian roths s'en aille  en prison,
notre liberté d'expression aussi, vous devez
penser que votre pouvoir sur vos vidéos,
vos pensées sont vos commentaires et vos
déplacements sont tous restreints, supprimés et
censurés, ce qui signifie que vous vivez dans une
tyrannie fasciste
libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matériaux trahit une croyance que son
pouvoir réside dans une disparité d'
information
encore plus de connaissances pour l'empire
même l  ess
juliansubstances
ce sont les mots d'un
intellectuel c'est la personne qui est
emprisonnée à l'intérieur de la
prison de belmar pouvez-vous l'imaginer
il est vraiment dans ses propres mots lisez lisez
ce qu'il a à dire pour lui-même même si je l'ai
fait taire mais ses mots seront partis
un autre  le journaliste a été
injustement
emprisonné cet été craig barry est en ecosse
nous avons la chance de l'avoir
avec nous aujourd'hui et nous attendons avec
impatience ce qu'il aura à dire
quand il sortira du tribunal
est
[Music]
yeah
okay
you
did '  ne me dites pas sur
[Applaudissements]
juste un peu carol
oh allez
[Musique]
nier cette extradition
[Applaudissements]
notre
presse libre est un combat
alors rejoignez-nous essentiel
alors chantez vos louanges pour lui
vous devez être libéré
s'il était
seul
pas de crime  a-t-il commis
[Musique]
manifestement
une parodie de justice
o biden ne peut pas gagner
et johnson doit être verruqueux
minuit
vous avez pris votre décision
mais assange doit être libéré
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
obtenez cette image
et manipulations et meurtres et
la tyrannie étant établie dans notre
dos alors que nous pensions qu'internet
était un mécanisme pour
accroître la liberté, nous avons découvert
par julian assange et ed snowden qu'il
était utilisé comme un mécanisme pour
établir un pouvoir totalitaire toujours plus grand
sur le monde
et maintenant nous avons une décision en
cours  à un
moment au cours des deux dernières années
où nous avons été entraînés dans une
dystopie totalitaire,
nous ne sommes pas seulement à l'écoute d'Assange
emprisonné,
mais presque le monde entier à un moment
ou à un autre enfermé au nom du
mensonge au nom de la manipulation dans  le
nom de la grande technologie, de la grande industrie pharmaceutique et des grandes
entreprises qui prennent le contrôle du
monde en collaboration avec l'armée
en collaboration avec l'appareil d'État,
ses agences de renseignement et oui en
collaboration avec tous les organes de
presse du monde dans le
courant dominant qui sont devenus
les
outils du client
gardien l'indépendant et tous ces
journaux de chat clap absurdes, puis
facebook
médias sociaux twitter
tous les  youtube tous se sont engagés dans
des campagnes mondiales de censure et de
manipulation de la population mondiale entière
pour soutenir cette tyrannie
nous avons quelques occasions de briser
cela ils ont établi une tyrannie en
autriche en allemagne en australie au cours des
dernières semaines ils essaient  pour aller dans
cette direction maintenant, nous devons nous dresser
contre cette prise de position le 18 assister
aux manifestations de masse à l'extérieur de Downing
Street faire tomber le gouvernement
mobiliser le peuple faire un
mouvement révolutionnaire mondial pour changer l'
équilibre des pouvoirs
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement du  états-unis d'
amérique les états-unis ont demandé l'exposition
de m. assange à des accusations tribales
et ont légitimement agi illégalement en
obtenant et en publiant des
documents classifiés m.
de la loi sur l'extradition de 2003 en raison de
son état mental
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les états-unis font appel d'une décision le
l'appel a été tenu par une cour divisionnaire
lord bernice de fontaine loi
juge en chef et droit de la justice pa  ul droid
les 27 et 28 octobre 2021, m.
assange
a indiqué qu'il conteste
les décisions du dj sur les questions qui
ont été tranchées contre lui et qu'il sécurisera
ces questions
mais qu'elles n'étaient pas devant le tribunal de
cette audience
cette audience était limitée à la question  de
savoir si le DJ avait tort de conclure que l'
état mental de M. Sanders était tel
qu'il serait oppressant,
les États-Unis d'Amérique ont fait valoir que
le DJ s'était trompé dans ses conclusions
sur l'état mental de M. Assange et
que, de toute façon, les États-
Unis avaient donné un  nombre d'assurances
qui rend les dj concernés m. assange a
fait valoir que la dj était en droit de parvenir à
la conclusion qu'elle a tirée et que les
assurances n'étaient pas suffisantes pour conduire
à une conclusion différente
dans le cadre d'une procédure d'extradition que
l'État qui
demande cette tradition peut donner
des assurances quant aux laissez-passer telles que les
conditions dans lesquelles la personne concernée
sera détenue
si elle est extradée l'assurance de ce
k  ind sont des engagements solennels offerts
par un gouvernement à un autre pour les
motifs exposés dans l'arrêt qui est rendu ce
jour le tribunal a accueilli l'
appel au motif que le dj ayant
décidé que le seuil de à pour la
décharge en vertu de l'article 91 de l'
extradition après en  2003 a été faite ou
a notifié les États-Unis d'une
vue provisoire pour donner la possibilité d'offrir des
assurances au tribunal et b
les États-Unis ont maintenant fourni au
Royaume-Uni un ensemble d'assurances
qui répondent aux conclusions spécifiques du DJ
quatre assurances ont été offertes  par les États-Unis
dans une note diplomatique datée du 5
février 2021,
le tribunal a jugé qu'il avait le pouvoir de
recevoir et d'examiner les assurances
nonobstant le fait qu'elles n'avaient été
offertes qu'après que le DJ
eut rendu une décision, le tribunal était
convaincu que les assurances
excluaient la possibilité de m.
assange fait l'objet de
mesures administratives spéciales ou est détenu dans les locaux de l'ada
florence,
soit en essai gratuit, soit après  r toute
condamnation à moins qu'après les assurances vih
il commette un acte futur qui
réside dans de telles conditions de
détention j'encourage les gens à lire le
reste de la décision c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle dont nous avions peur hier
[Rires]
le
voyage de nos amis continue
[  Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois les juges siégeant
parmi nous et délibérant parmi nous
ils entendraient nos voix
cela n'arrive plus
nous avons érigé ces beaux bâtiments et
ils sont à l'intérieur et nous sommes à l'extérieur ils
ne peuvent pas  écoutez nos voix mais
élevons les quand même
[Applaudissements]
pratiquement personne ne dit le contraire pas
une voix ne s'élève dans la société contre
nos revendications
qu'est ce donc
que le système judiciaire
n'a pas
un résultat conforme aux valeurs de cette
société
[Musique]
à moins d'être soutenus par la société si nous payons
nos impôts
pour l'actif de ces bâtiments
pour les salaires des juges
et nous
exigeons qu'ils reflètent les valeurs de la
la société que nous créons
[Applaudissements]
mais il y a une volonté absolue
de continuer
à sortir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] d'
accord merci beaucoup euh merci
beaucoup à tous les supporters d'être
venus ici merci à la presse euh d'être
venue  euh nous avons quelques
personnes qui ont été au tribunal ce
matin pour vous dire quelques mots euh maintenant
euh je vais juste dire une chose à propos de cette
décision du tribunal euh
et c'est ce
qu'il y a deux
absolument
incontestablement vrai  faits sur la politique britannique
il y en a un il y a deux
faits absolument incontestablement vrais sur la
politique britannique en ce moment l'
un est
qu'il y avait une fête à downing street
le 18 décembre et l'autre est
que vous ne pouvez pas accepter les assurances de
l'uni  le gouvernement des états dans l'
affaire julian assange comme les juges semblent l'
avoir fait aujourd'hui mais vous en dire plus sur
ce qui s'est passé tout d'abord je
vais demander à craig murray qui
suit cette affaire depuis le
tout début  égrenant pour dire quelques mots
[Applaudissements]
merci
bien euh le jugement d'aujourd'hui
euh
était une victoire partielle
dans la mesure où le juge a conclu
que sur la preuve médicale
et sur la preuve des conditions dans les
prisons américaines
le magistrat avait pris
la bonne décision
en refusant d'extrader
Julian Assange,
cependant,
ils ont dit sur la base uniquement
des assurances diplomatiques des
États-Unis et de la note diplomatique
qu'ils acceptaient la parole
du gouvernement des États-Unis
quant aux conditions
dans lesquelles Julian serait
détenu et ils ont dit
que c'était parce qu'il s'agissait d'
assurances solennelles de  un état
bien sûr ce sont des assurances solennelles
de l'état dont les crimes de guerre et le
meurtre de civils ont été exposés par
julian assange
vous ne pouvez pas accepter ce genre d'
assurances du gouvernement des
états-unis
et le gouvernement des états-unis
a rompu précisément ce genre  d'
assurances dans d'autres affaires judiciaires pour
lesquelles il existe une série d'arrêts à
la cour européenne  des droits de l'homme qui
ont été ignorés par ce tribunal, il s'agit donc d'
une étape de la bataille juridique
qui ira sur
l'autre point, bien sûr, c'est que jusqu'à présent,
ces audiences d'appel n'ont porté que
sur les sujets
contre lesquels le gouvernement des États-
Unis
faisait appel
des aspects  du jugement initial
euh
contre
lequel
euh
l'équipe assange a l'intention de faire appel n'a
pas encore été entendu
et ce sont la
liberté d'expression
ce sont
le droit de
ne pas être extradé pour des motifs politiques
ce sont le fait
que le traité d'extradition avec les
états-unis règle spécifiquement  sur
l'extradition politique
et nous avons le fait
que Julian Assange est en prison
pour avoir révélé aux crimes de guerre les plus
graves du monde
et qu'aucun de ceux qui ont commis les
crimes de guerre
n'est en prison et c'est toujours une position
ici aujourd'hui,
bien sûr,
nous en sommes légèrement
déçus  est très très difficile d'obtenir une audience équitable de
la part d'un système judiciaire au
Royaume-Uni dans tout ce
qui traverse la perception  ed intérêt
de l'état de sécurité que ce soit le royaume
-uni ou les états-unis
mais c'est une étape
dans la lutte
et la bataille juridique
et la bataille politique
continuera merci beaucoup
[musique]
[applaudissements]
merci
merci beaucoup craig
euh et  maintenant
le fiancé de stella morris julian assange et leur
militante extraordinaire dans ses propres droits vont
lui donner ses impressions sur
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui au tribunal stella
salut tout le monde et merci d'être venu
je tiens à souligner que la haute cour a
accepté
toutes les preuves médicales et  les
conclusions du magistrat que si
julian est extradé
et placé dans des conditions extrêmes d'
isolement
cela le conduira à se suicider
que l'extradition est oppressante
pourtant le tribunal de grande instance a
tranché contre julian
à cette occasion
sur la base d'
assurances euh politiques non-assurances
euh que les états-unis ont donné au gouvernement britannique
je dis des non-assurances
amnesty international dit des
non-assurances amnesty international h  en
analysant ces assurances et en disant
qu'elles ne sont pas fiables par nature,
elles intègrent la possibilité de
rompre ces assurances dans leur
formulation même
aujourd'hui,
cela fait presque un an que je me suis tenu
devant le tribunal
avec notre victoire du blocage de l'
extradition
pour l'année écoulée et le  l'année dernière deux
ans et demi
julian est resté à la prison de belmar
et en fait
il est détenu
depuis le 7 décembre 2010 sous une
forme ou une autre 11 ans pendant combien de temps
cela peut-il durer
aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale des droits de l'homme
quelle honte
comment  cynique
d'avoir cette décision ce jour-là
d'avoir l'un des plus grands
journalistes éditeurs
des
50 dernières années
dans une prison britannique
accusé d'avoir publié la vérité
sur
les crimes de guerre à propos des équipes de tuerie de la cia et en
fait chaque fois que nous avons
une audience
plus nous  en savoir plus sur
la nature abusive la
nature criminelle de cette affaire
julian a exposé les crimes des
tortionnaires de la cia des tueurs de la cia
et maintenant nous savons que cela  e les tueurs de la cia
prévoyaient de le tuer aussi
comment ce tribunal
comment ces tribunaux peuvent-ils
approuver une demande d'extradition
dans ces conditions
comment peuvent-ils
accepter
une extradition vers le pays qui a
comploté pour tuer julian qui a comploté pour
tuer un éditeur à cause de ce qu'il a
publié
ceci  va aux fondamentaux de la liberté de la presse
et de la démocratie
nous nous battrons
chaque génération a un combat épique à
mener et c'est le nôtre parce que julian
représente les fondamentaux de ce que
signifie vivre dans une société libre de ce
que signifie avoir la liberté
de la presse de quoi  cela signifie pour les journalistes de faire
leur travail sans avoir peur de
passer le reste de leur vie en
prison
le royaume-uni emprisonne les journalistes
ils emprisonnent julian
au nom d'une puissance étrangère qui
engage des poursuites vindicatives abusives contre un
journaliste et c'est ce que c'est  à propos de
j'exhorte tout le monde à se rassembler et à se
battre pour julian
julian représente toutes nos libertés et
tous nos droits
[Musique]
[Appl  ause]
merci beaucoup
oh soyons absolument clairs
[Applaudissements]
alors soyons clairs merci beaucoup
d'être venu mais ce ne sera pas la dernière
fois que nous serons devant une cour de
justice la procédure légale n'est pas
épuisée
il y aura  un autre appel sur lequel nous nous
battrons nous contesterons la décision selon
laquelle les assurances de vos ravisseurs
et assassins potentiels ne valent pas le
papier sur lequel ils sont imprimés le combat continue
[Applaudissements]
les avocats de Julian ont l'intention de
faire appel devant la cour suprême
sur cette décision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super
[Applaudissements]
tiens-le
oh
[Applaudissements]
mike met le micro dans leur visage ce n'est pas
sur mon
[Applaudissements]
bien
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Applaudissements  ]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
oh mon Dieu
c'est
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec le
sens de la justice défendre les
meurtriers de masse persécuter la droiture
l'appelant un narcissique pour avoir donné à l'
humanité,
il est notre socialisme
oh ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements
] vous faites du bien à tous les garçons d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
vous les gars ouais
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
euh
[Applaudissements]
wow
[Musique]
ok
c'est
euh
[Musique]
oui
le
résultat aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup
oui
merci
[Musique]
c'est
oh
ce matin
euh
[Musique
] c'est
[Musique]
quoi  l'heure de demain c'est
bon
[Musique]
je sais ce que c'est ça te donne envie de ne
pas dire la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
c'est
aussi
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
oui
je pense que nous sommes prêts
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
ouais euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wow
[Applaudissements]
oh
t  il regarde l'autre euh
et c'était un article vraiment intéressant
je ne l'ai jamais vu
euh
parce qu'ils n'ont aucun moyen de vérifier
si c'est plus facile
et aussi quand quelqu'un en a un bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est
[Musique  ]
et là
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh
c'est
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
euh
ça va
[Musique]
[La musique]
prend environ huit heures
[Applaudissements]
euh
[  Applaudissements
] pas eu le choix
[Applaudissements]
où tout le monde est
[Musique]
je pense que c'est une fille au laser,
n'est-ce pas
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Rires  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Musique] les
humains ont peur
que ce soit quelque chose
[Musique]
tout le monde
sans
il n'est pas possible d'avoir beaucoup d'énergie
pour le reste  du monde
[Applaudissements]
est que la police, ils ne savent pas
pourquoi sommes-nous là,
leurs commandants leur disent de se
débarrasser de ce blo  ck
de
manifestations
euh
avait continué à
protester nous rend énormes
étrangers
oui
les
médias grand public sont
[Musique]
est
les médias grand public ne peuvent pas ignorer
euh
oh
et nous devons tous travailler à domicile
[Musique]
est
euh
[Rires]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai
h
[Musique]
oui
euh
ça va être rapide
90 d'entre eux ne seront pas d'accord avec les
mesures prises je pense que c'est un gros
c'est
[Musique]
là  n'était pas
oh
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
i
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous vivons là-bas d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] d'
accord
[Musique]
tu sais
si tu sais
[  Musique]
[Rires]
tu vas sortir comme ça
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne verrai
pas comment tu vas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
ça
[Applaudissements]
ok
je n'ai pas compris
c'est
[Applaudissements]
euh
tu sais
[Applaudissements]
euh
ouais
ça n'arrivera pas de venir nous chercher
[Applaudissements  se]
comme
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
euh
pourquoi voudrais-je avoir un produit
mais ensuite ça descend
[Applaudissements]
oh
je ne savais pas
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
euh
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
elle est venue nous voir
euh
qu'est-ce que tu fais pour Noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements] d'
accord on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très étrange euh